the one thing that I really miss about
being at home and honestly is probably
being able to move around and to
exercise move in a straight line for a
long time generally my research is shift
based so we're on a 2 or 300 foot
research boat for a couple of months at
a time I try and get out into our small
boats to see the outside world as much
as possible when we're studying the
animals but you're pretty much confined
to that small space and there's not not
a place you can get off and go for a
hike as easily as you'd like to one of
my favorite things to do here is get in
a zodiac and when you've got this nice
calm stuff it's just cruise through it
sound of the ice kind of rolling around
and clinking is quite soothing and every
once in a while you see a whale in here
it's awesome
the Antarctic is a very distant place
for a lot of people it's an extreme
place it's a harsh place the animals
that are there are supremely adapted for
that environment there's a lot of
challenges that you face working in that
in those conditions there are technical
issues of how well your equipment is
going to hold up in an extreme condition
they're physical things just about being
really cold for a long period of time
and you need a lot of dexterity to do
some of these things in the colder you
are the less able you you are to do
those things
and I think it's sort of the combination
of those two that can lead to things
becoming dangerous if you're not
completely focused on things we can't do
things as well as you need to